Ah
[Music]
So, when I was young, there was no such educational institution in Korea
. In
a way, I couldn’t even dream. I
wanted to learn, but I had all the parts of my
dream.
Some kind of job that I need to take care of so that I can achieve my
dream like this  It's Daechi-dong in Gangnam, famous for that Gangnam Style.
K-pop is Korea's popular music. Dance music is the most
important worldwide and well,
so After School has been around for a while now
.  I'm a high school student and I learn Eden School dance after school
[Music]
I want to become a representative k-pop star of Korean.
Except for that, there are about 1,300 people on average.
Well, the schedule is
not particularly tight.  Give it to me
when it's over, and it's until the end of 10:30 There's a
special schedule, it's just popular
I
think it's the best way to communicate while watching with
friends. The main cultural building where friends with the same dream are
gathered  It's not hard at all because we're strong anyway.